I talked yesterday yesterday on the show
about this concept stochastic terrorism
okay
stochastic terrorism once again is when
through media messages through mass
communication methods if someone has a
large enough audience and they harp
about the need to take care of someone
in the public eye or the need to do
something about a person or an
organization it becomes statistically
more and more likely that someone in the
audience will actually be inspired to go
and do something in the real world as a
result of those mass communication
messages that they've heard Glenn Beck
famously was constantly ranting and
raving about the tides foundation with
all sorts of conspiracies and eventually
it actually inspired someone in his
audience to go and try to do something
about the tides foundation hopefully if
I recall the story correctly he was
stopped by police on his way to do that
thing now of course as as of current law
Glenn Beck cannot be found guilty in any
way for conspiring with that individual
there's no actual connection it's
through the mass messaging that that
stochastic terrorism is carried out this
got us into the conversation of the
impact of the attacks that we've been
seeing against these four ethnic
minority Congress women called
the squad and what we have now seen is
that the Illinois Republican County
Chairman's Association shared a meme
labeling them not the squad but the
jihad squad and they apparently either
realized that was a terrible idea
or deleted it after there was a whole
bunch of blowback after posting it and
they now are claiming oh that was an
unauthorized post to our social media
accounts it does not represent our
actual views the president of this
Republican group is Mark Shaw he said
quote I condemned this unauthorized
posting and it has been deleted I am
sorry if anyone who saw the image was
offended by the contents so this is
problematic for a variety of reasons
number one it again perpetuates the idea
that Muslims are terrorists and we've
talked before I have no hesitation
whatsoever to point out that there are
significant portions of problematic
beliefs among large numbers of the world
Muslim population
but perpetuating this idea that merely
by being Muslim there is some
terroristic link including by members of
the American Congress unless you have
really solid evidence of that you
shouldn't say it it's disgusting and
it's disastrous from a logistical
standpoint
Alexandra Castillo Cortes is not Muslim
I Anna Presley is not Muslim as far as I
know so it doesn't even apply the two of
the four ethnic minority Congress women
that are being referred to here and more
importantly it furthers xenophobia and
again when it goes back to the
stochastic terrorism element it can
cause people to take real-world action
these members of Congress now require
beefed up security would any of you if
tomorrow I came to you and said breaking
news there's been an assassination
attempt against one of those four women
would any of you be surprised I don't
think so I don't think you can say that
that would be a surprising bit of news
given everything that's been going on
and the media rhetoric the rhetoric in
media from people on the right about
those four women and meanwhile the
Republicans won't pass the 9/11 Victims
Compensation Fund not exactly being
tough on terror right if you say hey we
we aren't even going to pass this simple
thing to actually deal with taking care
of the people that have been victimized
by actual radical Islamic ideology
rather than just four members of
Congress that we are slandering in this
way and once again the defenses are so
pathetic well David they didn't mean
jihad squad literally it's symbolism we
just disagree with them politically when
they said send her home at Trump's North
Carolina rally it wasn't literally sent
her home it was symbolically saying we
disagree respectfully with your politics
when the police officer said Alexandria
Castillo Cortez deserves to be shot the
police chief said it was inappropriate
but it's not a literal threat from this
cop this cop is not actually going to
shoot her that cop has been suspended we
learned in the last 24 hours by the way
and similarly the jihad squad label now
they're saying well we're not literally
saying they are radical MA
in jihadists it's just symbolism for we
disagree with their politics the
cumulative effect here III almost
hesitate to talk about it because I
don't want it to happen the cumulative
effect is that someone may well be
pushed to do something in the real world
they used to pretend that the racists
and the Zeinab of xenophobes were just a
small portion they're not even
pretending anymore it's actually
campaign strategy I've said it last week
and I'll repeat it Trump and Pence are
now actually running on overtly
xenophobic rhetoric sort of guised as
nationalism and even more innocuously
patriotism we can see through it the
people on the right there's nothing for
them to see through they just like it
and this may well get Donald Trump
reelected that's the sickest part of it
all we are taking an audience poll
related to this issue on the David
Pakman show Instagram page make sure
you're following it at David Pakman show
and while you're there follow me at
David Pakman on Instagram as well we'll
take a quick break and be back after
this on a very very busy news day
today's sponsor is Skillshare and I'm
excited to tell you that everybody in
our audience is getting two entire
months of free access to Skillshare when
you click the link underneath this video
skill shares the site that offers over
25,000 online courses on almost any
topic you can imagine cooking meditation
photography video editing Photoshop
managing a small business almost an
endless list and whether you're trying
to get ahead in your career maybe you
want to learn new skills that will make
you better at your job you might just be
exploring a new hobby and you're trying
to find new ways to be creative in your
personal time skill shares the perfect
place to fully immerse yourself in
whatever you're trying to learn I really
enjoyed the class on more advanced video
editing techniques because it's
something I've been wanting to improve
at but have been very busy hosting the
david packard show for the last few
years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of acts
to every single class offered by
Skillshare after those two months if you
want to keep your subscription
Skillshare super affordable at less than
ten bucks a month get better at whatever
it is that you're passionate about or
discover something brand-new that you
didn't even know that you would love and
join skill shares other 7 million users
by clicking the link underneath this
video
[Music]